Put on your giant bear coat and spray yourself
down with your best zombie-scented perfume.
Because LÜT is back.
Wake up with the perfect sunny side egg breakfast
shaper
Or if you're in a hurry just floss with your
breakfast..... oh and take dessert with you
for later.
And don't forget to feed the squirrels out
of their own heads with this.
Send out stamps with your face on them at
the photo stamps store where you can upload
personalized photos and make your very own
stamps, and nobody will think you are vain,
at all.
Don't worry about it.
But if a gift with your face on is not good
enough, you can buy your friends and family
a piece of America, one square inch at a time.
At own a piece of America dot com you can
buy people their own land, even a piece of
a state for just $3.95 per square inch.
If you need something special for the lady
in your life there's a lot of sciencetacular
jewelry out there like this cyanobacteria
inspired necklace, these DNA and RNA matching
lockets, sloth rings....
Or this scariest necklace of all time.
That goes perfect with this hyper-realistic
baby mask.
Make your own "personalized" jewelry by taking
these pills filled with 24-karat gold leaf
that make you poop glittery gold!
And for ladies on the go they make this handy
dandy female pee device - Alright time to
move on!
If you're hungry you can cook something up
with this Kosher cookbook of imaginary animals
that reveals everything you need to know about
fictional beasts and whether or not it's kosher
to eat them including centaurs, basilisk,
and all these mysterious monsters.
Or keep it simple and just have some sushi.....
doormat
Better yet just shoot sushi out of this sushi
bazooka which if eaten off of one of these
placemats would be rated awesome.
Lionel Richie Break.
Hello...."is it me your cooking for?" or is
it brie....?
Either way don't forget to season your meal
with sadness.... courtesy of a jar of salt
made from human tears.
Later the adults can get sauce-y with some
Vodka made from cow's milk
Guess what?
Twelve female styrofoam heads all for sale
at the same place.
Get 'em now!
Blocking out sights and sounds from your head
is easy with the hibermate.
A luxury eye mask with removable ear muffs
that totally blocks out light and has been
rated safe for use in environments up to 90db.
Rate H for hairy is this Hairy chest sweater
that at least matches your hairy Wookie longboard
from Geoff McCleary of Weirdboards.
And if it's raining you'll be equipped with
your windshield wiper goggles and submarine
umbrella complete with periscope.
But remember if it's too hot your tights will
melt off.
We're almost done so curl up with your USB
leg warmers, pull out the pillow remote, go
to sleep sitting upright.... and as always....
thanks for watching.